willkommen zu aktuellen Sendung im
Seminar Philosophie der Aufklärung heute
geht es um gegenwärtige Theorien der
Aufklärung heute befassen wir uns mit
Jürgen Habermas und seiner Theorie des
kommunikativen Handelns das ist sein
Hauptwerk kann man sagen das ist Anfang
der 1980er Jahre geschrieben worden und
es ist in mehreren Bänden erschienen
hier befassen wir uns jetzt heute mit
zentralen Zitaten aus dem ersten Bahn
zum Thema
handlungsrationalität und
gesellschaftliche Rationalisierung
inwiefern kann dieses Thema
handlungsrationalität mit dem Problem
der Aufklärung überhaupt in eine
Beziehung gebracht werden damit wollen
wir uns heute befassen wir haben noch
ein paar andere Fragen was versteht aber
was unter Rationalität wir haben gesehen
jede Theorie der Aufklärung hat einen
speziellen Vernunft oder Rationalität
Begriff dann wollen wir viele Fragen
fassen was habe Maß unter kommunikative
Rationalität versteht und inwiefern
kommunikative Vernunft eine Form von
Aufklärung sein kann natürlich wollen
wir auch uns noch am Ende kurz fragen
wie sich seine Theorie zu den bereits
behandelten Theorien verhält und wir
wollen es natürlich auch fragen worin
Unmündigkeit nach habermaß bestehen kann
abermals hat ein sehr speziellen
Rationalität oder Vernunftbegriff der
nicht so sehr mit Erkenntnis zu tun hat
mit Methode auch vielleicht nicht so
viel mit Vernetzung in der Enzyklopädie
mit Rezeption sondern für ihn hat
Rationalität immer etwas mit Handeln zu
tun handeln von Subjekten in
Gesellschaft und zwar Handeln durch
Sprache man kann auch von sprachhandlung
sprechen von performativen Akten
dahinter steht natürlich die Theorie der
Sprechakte von Austin und dann in der
verfeinerten in Form von John sirl
Stichwort illokutionäre Akt also
Sprachhandlungen sind Handlungen der
Äußerung die nicht nur beschreiben was
getan wird oder was ist nicht nur
semantisch oder deskriptiv sind indem
sie mit einer äußeren verbunden sind
gerade auch was vollziehen also zum
Beispiel versprechen
auffordern
Taufen das sind Sprechakte die durch die
Äußerung etwas vollziehen deswegen hat
aus den auch von performativen Akten
gesprochen darum geht es ihm um diese
Sprechakte in der Gesellschaft
für ihn ist ganz wichtig dass die
Rationalität einer Handlung einer
sprachhandlung immer kritisiert werden
können muss und zwar kritisiert werden
durch eine Gesellschaft
er spricht hier auch von einem
transsubjektiven Geltungsanspruch das
ist jetzt nicht genau dasselbe wie
objektiv als er versucht jetzt über den
Begriff der transsubjektivität
Objektivität zu erklären objektivität
ist fahrermaß nichts was irgendwie über
der Welt schwebt objektive Tatsachen die
losgelöst sind von der sprach Pragmatik
der Subjekte sondern Objektivität wird
durch Intersubjektivität
geschaffen erzeugt aber eben nicht
relativ auf verschiedene Subjekte
sondern eben im Sinne einer Einigung
einer rationalen Einigung von Subjekten
so dass das Subjekt am Ende gar nicht
mehr entscheidend ist für die Geltung
einer Tatsache mit einer Begründung für
den Geltungsanspruch aber er sagt eben
nicht objektiv im strengen Sinn ist
sondern transubjektiv und sehr
interessante Begriff der hier eine Rolle
spielt
er sagt auch dass es um die Rationalität
derer geht die an dieser kommunikativen
Praxis der Praxis des Gebens und Lebens
von Gründen das kennen wir schon von
Platon lockern die donai also
Rechenschaft ablegen ein Argument geben
das also die Rationalität sich daran
bemisst an dieser kommunikativen Praxis
des Gebens und Nehmens von guten Gründen
ob die Äußerung begründet werden können
er spricht hier auch von einer Form von
kommunikativer Rationalität die er jetzt
durch eine Theorie der Argumentation
angemessen erklären möchte kommunikative
Rationalität ist die das entscheidende
Wort wir hatten schon andere Formen von
Rationalität kennengelernt wir hatten
bei Immanuel Kant eine Form von
Rationalität als selbst denken als
autonomes denken kennengelernt das nicht
so sehr
intersubjektiv gedacht war wie bei
habermasken Blick auf die Sprache obwohl
bei kann natürlich auch der öffentliche
Gebrauch der Vernunft eine große Rolle
gespielt hat der aber nicht durch
Sprachgemeinschaft im Sinne der
Sprechakte zu verstehen was sondern ihr
im Sinne der Publizität also ihr im
Sinne des Mediums der geschriebenen
sprachen wir haben noch andere
Rationalität Begriffe kennengelernt zum
Beispiel in der Enzyklopädie von Dieter
da ist der rationalitätsbegriff die
sinnvolle manchmal kritische
verweisungsstruktur und die adäquate
Abbildung
des Wissens von unseren menschlichen
Vermögen also von dem Gedächtnis da sind
die historischen Wissenschaften von
unserer Vernunft da ist die Logik die
Philosophie vor allem und von unserer
Einbildungskraft da ist dann die ganze
Ästhetik im Enzyklopädie systematisch
geordnet wie ein Baum auch hier verbirgt
sich ein spezielles Rationalität ideal
dann mache ich auch oben rechts dann
noch einen Link zu dieser Sendung hinein
ja darum geht es also man soll
kommunikative Rationalität durch eine
Theorie der Argumentation
weiterverständlich machen er spricht
jetzt hier von der Stärke eines
Arguments die sich an der Triftigkeit
der Gründe vermisst
das heißt es geht darum dass in der
Argumentation der verschiedenen Subjekte
die anderen teilnehmenden Personen nicht
nur überredet werden manipuliert werden
etwas zu Glauben sind dass sie überzeugt
werden das also die
Stärke der Gründe die anderen Menschen
gewissermaßen zwingt aber nicht zwingend
mit Gewalt sondern wenn dann mit Gewalt
des besseren arguments das eben
Überzeugungskraft hat
es geht hier nicht um Überwältigung von
anderen Subjekten sondern es soll ein
rationaler Diskurs etabliert werden dem
sich andere durch die Einsicht in die
wir sagt im Stärke des Arguments fügen
eine Bereitschaft sich Kritik
auszusetzen wird ebenfalls erwartet man
soll also nicht nur starke Gründe
entwickeln und den Folgen müssen oder
können sondern eben auch sich selbst
immer wieder dieser diesen kritischen
Diskurs des Gebens und Lebens von
Gründen stellen und sich gegebenenfalls
auch selbst in Frage zu stellen und die
eigenen Auffassung zu modifizieren im
lichtetes besseren arguments der anderen
dann hat er noch ein interessante
Theorie der Selbsttäuschung die für ihn
auch mit Rationalität im weitesten Sinne
zu tun hat das ist für ihn die
Irrationalität wer sich über sich selbst
täuscht wer sich also was vormacht wäre
vielleicht auch zu sehr rationalisiert
das heißt derjenige oder diejenige muss
sich aufklären lassen das bezieht sich
wiederum auf das vorherige Zitat dass
man sich einer Kritik aussetzen muss und
sich auch korrigieren lassen muss also
man muss eben in der Lage sein sich zu
seiner Subjektivität reflexiv zu
verhalten und diese Reflexivität die ist
natürlich wie wir sagen schon ein Zug
des aufklärungsgedanken haben wir bei
Hegel gesehen mache ich oben rechts in
links rein haben wir auch bei horkammer
Adorno gesehen dass die Aufklärung immer
eine Reflexivität benötigt weil sie
sonst Gefahr läuft totalitär zu werden
oder eben gerade in eine Dialektik sich
zu verstricken und am Ende in das zu
führen wo Franz geeinigt die Menschheit
befreien möchte ganz unten sagt er noch
die Form der Argumentation die der
aufklärungssystematischer
Selbsttäuschung dient nenne ich
therapeutische Kritik und hier spielt er
an auf das Modell bei Sigmund Freud
zwischen Arzt und analysanden das ist
natürlich interessant wie wenn man das
auch psychologisch oder sogar
psychotherapeutisch verstehen kann die
Aufklärung aus der Unmündigkeit die
natürlich auch selbst verschuldet ist
diese Irrationalität ist nicht ein
Schicksal sondern wir täuschen und
natürlich systematisch das heißt
natürlich auch letztendlich zurechenbar
und schuldhaft über uns selbst und
dieser rationale Diskurs des Lebens von
Gründen der soll eben im Sinne der
Aufklärung dazu führen dass wir aus
unserer selbst verschuldeten
Unmündigkeit so kann man diese Form der
defizitären Kommunikation hier auch
verstehen entgehen können das war jetzt
ein kurzer Einblick in die Theorie der
Aufklärung bei Jürgen Habermas die
sprachaufklärung auch wenn er sie so
nicht ausdrücklich nennen kann man doch
eine solche Theorie daraus
rekonstruieren jetzt gibt es noch zum
Schluss ein Ausblick auf die nächste und
letzte Sitzung dieses Seminars da soll
es um die Frage gehen was digitale
Aufklärung ist wir werden uns dazu mit
digitalen enzyklopädin Befassen mit
Wikipedia und anderen und schauen wie
sich diese modernen Internet bedienen
auf die herkömmlichen enzyklopädin vor
allem auf die aussieht glaube die
bezieht und im Weg werden sie auf
digitale Weise den Gedanken der
Aufklärung fortführt und auch in die
gegenwärtige Zeit vielleicht auch sogar
in die Zukunft überführt bedanke mich
vielmals für die Aufmerksamkeit bis zur
nächsten Folge